now we have a very very very hairy
expression and once again I'm going to
see if you can simplify this and I'll
give you a little time to do it so this
one is even crazier than the last few
we've looked at we've got wise and XY
z-- and X Squared's and X's and well
more just X YS and Y Squared's and on
and on and on and there will be a
temptation because you see Y here and a
y here to say oh maybe I can add this
negative 3y plus this for X Y somehow
since I see Y and a y but the important
thing to realize here is that a y is
different than an XY thinking about if
they were numbers if Y was 3 and then X
was a 2 then a Y would be a 3 while an
XY would have been a 6 and a y is very
different than a Y squared once again if
the Y took on the value 3 then the Y
squared would be the value 9 so even
though you see the same letter here they
aren't the same I guess you can't you
cannot add these two or subtract these
two terms so Y is different than a Y
squared is different than an X Y now
with that said let's see if we can if
there is anything that we can simplify
so first let's think about the Y terms
so you have a negative 3y there do we
have any more Y terms yes we do
we have this 2y right over there so I'll
just write it out I'll just reorder it
so we have negative negative 3y plus 2i
plus 2i now let's think about and we can
I'm just going in an arbitrary order but
since our next term is an XY term let's
think about all of the XY terms so we
have plus 4xy right over here so let me
just write down I'm just reordering the
whole expression plus 4xy and then I
have minus 4xy right over here so minus
4xy
then let's go to the x squared terms I
have negative 2 times x squared or minus
2 x squared so let's look at this so I
have minus 2 x squared
do I have any other X Squared's yes I do
I have this 3x squared right over there
so plus 3 X Squared's and then let's see
- why I have an X term right over here
and that actually looks like the only X
term so that's plus 2x and then I only
have one y squared term
I'll circle that in orange so plus plus
y squared so all I have done is I've
reordered the statement and I've
color-coded it based on the type of term
we have and now it should be a little
bit simpler so let's try it out
if I have negative three of something
plus two of that something what do I
have or another way to say it if I have
two of something and I subtract three of
that what am I left with
well I'm left with negative one of that
something so I could write negative I
could write negative 1y or I could just
write negative Y and another way to
think about it but I like to think about
it intuitively more is what's the
coefficient here it is negative 3 what's
the coefficient here it's 2 we're
obviously both dealing they're both Y
terms not X Y terms not Y squared terms
just Y and so negative 3 plus 2 is
negative 1 or negative 1 Y is the same
thing as negative Y so those simplify to
this right over here now let's look at
the X Y terms if I have 4 of this for
XYZ and I were to take away 4 x wise how
many XY is am I left with
well I'm left with no x wise or you
could say add the coefficients 4 plus
negative 4 gives you 0 x wise either way
these two cancel out if I for something
and I take away those 4 of that
something I'm left with none of them and
so I'm left with no X wise and then I
have right over here I could have
written 0 X Y but that wouldn't you know
that that seems unnecessary then right
over here I have my x squared terms
negative 2 plus 3 is 1 or another way of
saying if I have three X Squared's and I
were to take away two of those X
Squared's I'm left with 1 x squared so
this right over here simplifies to 1 x
squared or I could literally just write
x squared 1 x squared is the same thing
as x squared so plus x squared and then
these there's nothing really left to
simplify so plus 2 X plus 2 X plus y
squared plus
plus y-squared and we're done and
obviously you might have got an answer
in some other order but the order in
which I write these terms don't matter
just matters that you were able to
simplify it to these four terms